okay let's go next to our caller from
the 732 area code caller from seven
three two go ahead
hey David can you hear me yeah I can hey
um so I don't know how much you study or
look into gentrification and suburban
white into the cities but do you think
it's gonna be a long-term trend do you
think that young homeowners are gonna
stay in the city or they gonna move back
to the suburbs what's gonna happen the
suburbs what's your take on that yes so
historically the way it often goes is
that people go from cities to suburbs as
they get older because they want more
space often when they start having kids
and they're less into the sort of city
life I think that what sort of changed
that trend is that now there's a
reorganization where in total like above
and beyond the young people who come to
cities and the slightly less young
people who leave cities you're seeing
more and more people wanting to live in
cities and that's part of why we've seen
cities like New York and Boston and San
Francisco and Washington DC have real
estate just astronomically shoot up so I
think in total you're still going to see
the trend of people looking for more
space and moving out of cities over time
but probably to a lesser degree than
we've seen in the past because there's
like a renewed urbanization in a lot of
America all right thank you very much
Wow simple one very straightforward
appreciate the call thank you